what's up this is GQ recommends and
today we're talking about five style
moves you should try in the new year
[Music]
so it's 2023 a new year maybe you have
some resolutions maybe some of them are
style focused maybe they're not but
we've got five style trends that we
really think you should try this year
yeah if your wardrobe's feeling a little
bit tired or you find yourself in like a
bit of a stylistic rut I think what we
tend to do is just like home in on a few
pieces that we feel like will rejuvenate
what we're wearing and just work
throughout the rest of the year yeah
absolutely I mean some of these pieces
we're going to talk about today are
something you already have in your
closet but maybe you haven't thought
about in a while it's more that in 2023
it feels like they have a renewed or
relevance how we want to wear them now
feels different at least to us than how
you might have worn them in the past so
if you're looking for inspiration look
no further
striped button-ups
haven't these been around for like ever
I mean it's not a new thing but I think
that the stripe button up has kind of
been coming back in maybe sort of like a
90s way they're like I don't want to say
oversized but they've they've definitely
got a flow to them it's kind of
refreshing to have something that is not
so over the top not so trendy not so
like eye-catching I mean it's a classic
piece just because it has buttons
doesn't mean you have to button it I
think maybe that's also part of the
charm is like you can wear a button up
in a few different ways you can wear it
with a tie you can wear it with an open
collar or just straight up open like I
am and you know show off your cool
graphic tee or something like that which
you should yes yeah thanks
[Music]
one we particularly like right now is
from this brand sunflower it's got that
classic vertical stripes but if you look
a little bit closer the stripes kind of
vary in color which gives it a little
bit more depth than just you know a
solid white background and and like one
color it's also not like a pure white is
it like to my eyes it looks almost
accurate or like off-white yeah it's not
so like bleach white which is maybe
easier to wear with a lot of uh you know
a lot of color palettes and it feels
like it's telegraphing that like I'm
wearing this because I want to not
because I have to I like the the fit of
this too is really nice it's relaxed
it's not I wouldn't say oversized but a
classic fit honestly another brand that
we really like has always been
consistent with their button UPS is Alex
Mill I mean they have several great
stripe button ups at a really good price
point really great quality and maybe a
little bit more of a tailored fit but
like by no means is it
skinny at all it's become like a bit of
a trademark just because it's it's so
easy going in nature and really feels
like a button up that you can pretty
much wear anytime more so than a solid
shirt I think
[Music]
black Blazers
what I like about the black blazer is
that it feels edgy but it also feels
powerful for the last few years haven't
felt very powerful often it seems like
there's a lot of things out of our
control not to get too meta but if the
one thing you can control is the clothes
that you put on your body why not make
the conscious decision to wear things
that make you feel like the most
powerful version of yourself
I just like how they look like yeah it's
fair
you probably already have a black suit
for those occasions
that really require a black suit and
like a black tie why not just take the
jacket portion and wear it in your
everyday life yeah that's why we're here
the black blazer can contrary to what
you might think be worn with a lot of
different pants so I like black Blazers
and like almost any form I can get him
but I particularly like this black
blazer from ludan which is the aptly
named 70s Blazer it's got these super
beefy lapels which are actually Notch
which is kind of interesting usually you
only see a lapel this size if it's a
peak but it's also got pretty
substantial ticket Pockets really big
buttons right here and it just fits in
the way that you want it to it's slouchy
and less structure than you would
imagine it would be but it hugs your
body in the ways that you want it to IT
projects that type of power we were
talking about totally it's not like uh
like a frumpy suit but it's also not a
super slim like I just got this from the
Taylor suit it's like it's kind of in
between it feels casual enough that it's
not intimidating to wear in a less
formal setting we also like different
versions of the black blazer it doesn't
have to be
you know very kind of specific 70s style
another one we like is from Celine it's
a double breasted black blazer we've
been really feeling double-breasted
suits and Blazers here at the office
I've seen a lot but haven't quite seen
too many black versions but I think that
is going to change this year ASAP
Rocky's already worn it oh sure you're
right I forgot about that he looks great
in it too
[Music]
crewneck sweater vest
you and I both wear sweater vest but who
is the person that should try a crew
neck sweater vest we're already on board
with the v-neck sweater vest Resurgence
but I think the crew neck itself feels a
little bit less expected for whatever
reason sweater vests are more common in
v-neck form maybe it's to show off a tie
or a button down this feels more casual
it's a little bit loosey-goosey so we
like crewneck sweater rests in almost
any form you can name but I'm really
feeling this one from our main Girl
Molly G because she is like the foremost
sweater vest virtuoso of her generation
she's a British designer she happens to
specialize in these types of erstwhile
granddaddy fabrics and then rinse it all
through a punk lens so this for example
is like a classic take on an Argyle
except there's no diamonds it's just
straight squares she also does a lot of
really cool freaky Fair Isles well the
sweater dress is a really great layering
piece I mean
you couldn't wear it with with no shirt
underneath and that would be a Vibe but
uh if you don't want to do that they
look great with just like a plain white
tee underneath but in a more classic
sense let's just with like a button up
underneath is really great too we also
really liked another version from Susie
a little bit easier of a price point but
just as stylish I would definitely start
there maybe cup a few
oh
leather pants
so you're probably aware that leather
exists you know that it's a material you
might even have like a really sick moto
jacket or a cafe racer made out of
leather but the leather goods that I'm
really feeling this year and that I
think you will too are actually leather
pants I think around you know the 2015s
2016s there was a lot of like rock star
skinny leather pants that's not really
the type of leather pants that we're
talking about now so I'm actually
wearing a pair here but they should
essentially fit like a crisp pair of
straight jeans the pair that we're
looking at right here from Ernest W
Baker are really sick you can't tell all
that well but they've got like a slight
flare at the bottom which is really in
line with some of the other pants that
we're feeling right now but the
essential silhouette is pretty familiar
it's got that very similar denim like
silhouette with two pockets here just a
simple fly zipper there I mean leather
as a material is more expensive than a
you know denim those pants are super
nice but they'll cost you around 600 ish
bucks it's kind of an investment and at
that point you you do want something
that's made with nice leather but that's
not the only option you can find plenty
of faux leather options synthetic
leather options out there that look just
as great there's a pair we really like
from sephir they feel remarkably similar
to the real thing they'll run you about
200 bucks which is you know not nothing
but it's definitely an easier price
point to get into
freaky clogs the last Trend we're
talking about is a pair of clogs and not
just any cloths yeah not just any clogs
you might be thinking of like a
Birkenstock but what we're talking about
is honestly more of a classic like very
chunky like Swedish clog and I'm saying
it's it's not like completely made out
of wood although there are those we're
talking about some clogs with some
serious heel action something with like
two inches worth of like of a platform I
think this is just building on a wave
that honestly Birkenstock has already
like ushered in with their Boston which
is a great alternative one of the bigger
names in this world is a brand called
Troll and torp they're known for these
wood Soul clogs which I'm wearing today
as you can see they've got a pretty
substantial heel and they've got these
nails like nailing down the upper clogs
they're not really a new thing like just
like a lot of the pieces we're talking
about they've been bubbling up they've
been bubbling up though yeah for sure
and I think uh people are reframing how
they see this like very traditional shoe
that is
a bit ugly to some people but definitely
eye-catching so it's not a new thing but
I think how people are wearing it now
makes it really fresh and contemporary
they're like an everyday shoe you can
wear them with any outfit really uh it
might be I know for you hard to wrap
your head around
I'm only trying to get on your level Joe
but it's like what you said about
leather pants it's like just think of
them as another pant with these I just
think of them as an another pair of
shoes at the end of the day I just kind
of wear them with everything with dress
pants Jeans cargo pants cords like you
name it so I guess what makes these
slightly more approachable to me is that
like if you look at the actual material
they're made out of it's just like a
Supple gray suede it's not too freaky
yeah totally totally I mean Suede Shoes
gray color it's not too intimidating but
there's a pony hair version that we
really like so if you want to add not
just texture and not just height but a
crazy animal print to it you can go that
way I've seen some also in like
shearling in like I don't know in a
variety of different Gucci make a pair
that's like decked out in its
interlocking G pattern oh yeah with the
horse bits with the horse bits with more
studs it can get really crazy so if you
really want to step up your shoe game
like
literally uh in 2023 a pair of wild
freaky clogs is definitely gonna do that
for you
well that's a wrap thank you guys as
always for watching and if you like
anything we talked about all the links
are in the description right below